it has come out breaking news that
president joe biden
uh has coveted cnn breaking news right
there president joe biden who is fully
vaccinated and boosted twice has tested
positive
for covid 19. so obviously this is just
happening over the last couple minutes
our cold open was sort of a silly biden
compilation our cold close was also a
silly biden compilation so just real
quick let me just share some thoughts i
i do not know how severe it is
whether it is serious or not the guy
obviously is up there in years i make a
lot of fun of the guy there is
obviously some health stuff going on
with him cognitively
and probably in other ways that we have
no idea
that being said as i have said many
times the president of the united states
is the pilot of the plane and the
country is the plane and i wish
that joe biden was in better shape than
joe biden is coveted or not i wish that
i believed that the president of the
united states was competent and
physically and mentally up to the job
it's a tough job
some of you watching this have tough
jobs but that's a real tough job right
and you got to be real sharp and you got
to be able to manage all sorts of
actually unimaginable things that could
happen all day long but we know he's not
up to the job
but that being said i wish him well i do
not want this guy to get sick i don't
even want to say
the phrase because you know what the
phrase is if biden is unable to serve as
president of the united states or if he
passed away or whatever it might be you
do know what happens after that
yeah we get president kamala harris we
get vice president at least temporarily
nancy pelosi
let's not forget that evil soulless
gavin newsom was at the white house last
week having secret meetings with jill
biden the president's wife with ronald
klein who is the chief of staff at the
white house with the vice president like
who knows what they know what they are
planning all of those things but i take
no pleasure in this uh look hopefully he
recovers and then we can go back to
making fun of the guy as normal um
because he he needs to be made fun of
right like we have to actually make fun
of these people and call out the
nonsense
that the mainstream media will not do uh
but just know like just the reality of
politics politics is a messy game there
are a lot of people
including probably kamala harris i just
did it there myself who are licking
their chops
they really are because they know that
the machine is done with him if you just
look at what's happened i mean look what
we've been covering over the last say
three weeks here right um the machine
has started to realize that he is
useless that whatever they needed him to
do which basically was just get the
presidency just get the dems back in
office just get rid of orange man he
accomplished that
the machine used him he used the machine
big tech hid the hunter biden thing all
of the stuff
he got in and then they didn't think it
was going to break down this quickly
they are in for a freaking disaster in
the midterms and the machine doesn't
need him anymore so
we'll see how the media reacts to this i
mean that's the other piece of course
because they're going to try to hide it
because maybe they're not fully done
with him yet i guarantee you
uh if this was trump when trump got
coveted i mean immediately it was 25th
amendment and impeachment 17 and all the
rest of it uh so we shall see but joking
aside i i do not wish the president
anything other than well wishes at the
moment and i hope he recovers and i do
not want president kamala harris and i
do not want vice president nancy pelosi
and and i also just think putting aside
all of that like we just don't need more
craziness at the moment we really don't
like
there are wins that we've been talking
about here and there's a feeling like oh
we can start getting things back getting
the country right all of that stuff
modeling florida across the nation make
america florida fight for freedom again
all of those things find the right
leaders etc
so maybe we can just kind of focus and
sit on that